salut romain ça je suis né j'ai pas
capté à eux n'ont toujours pas je veux
faire un truc je sais pas si c'est sûr
que ça m'a non ça va pas qu'est ce que
qu'est-ce qui se passe je sais pas j'ai
l'impression qu'on n'est plus sur la
même longueur d'onde
ouah ok donc tu as tu avais préparé
cette blague depuis les bureaux
vous êtes peut-être déjà au courant si
vous me suivez sur instagram j'ai un
nouveau slip ok je précise pour ceux qui
savent pas pour la sortie de la saison 2
de the boys prime vidéo m'a envoyé des
signes aux couleurs des super héros de
la série ils ont la particularité de
protéger mes attributs de la chaleur des
bactéries et des ondes
alors c'est les slips qui ont cette
particularité là c'est pas les super
héros
ce serait fou comme super pouvoirs
l'idée c'est de garder mon matériel à
l'abri tout envie nous atant la série en
slip donc et je me suis dit que c'était
l'occasion de faire un petit point sur
les effets des ondes sur notre santé
parce qu'on entend dire pas mal de
choses gourmet de quoi on parle déjà ses
ondes c'est quoi exactement
en l'occurrence quand on parle dont
parle d' onde électromagnétique c'est à
dire la combinaison d'onde électrique et
d'ondés magnétiques
d'où le nom on s'est quand même bien
fait et des objets qui généra
rayonnement électromagnétique bas il y
en a plein auquel on est exposé
régulièrement voire carrément tous les
jours le téléphone portables et les
antennes-relais le wifi le bluetooth et
globalement tous qui transmet des
informations sans fil là on parle d'
onde à haute fréquence mais aussi
certains appareils électroménagers parce
que tous les appareils électriques
émettent un rayonnement
électromagnétique à basse fréquence donc
vous voyez en vrai ça fait pas mal de
temps qu'on est exposé aux ondes à
longueur de journée d'ailleurs ça fait
une bonne cinquantaine d'années que les
chercheurs se penchent sur les effets
que ça peut avoir sur notre santé
d'autant que ça il y en a de plus en
plus donc on baigne dedans plus ou moins
en permanence on a même trouvé un terme
pour désigner sa électro smaug
alors c'est vrai que ça fait un peu non
dj mais en fait pas du tout ça désigne
ce bain d'ondés électromagnétique dans
lequel on nage en permanence bon mais
alors qu'est ce qu'elles nous font ces
ondes exactement le premier truc qui
vous vient à l'esprit sûrement c'est le
cancer
alors est-ce que les ondes sont
cancérogènes
oui et non on va pas refaire le débat
est ce qu'on doit dire cancérigènes ou
cancérogènes bon ok alors dans l'absolu
on dit cancérogènes quand on parle de
quelque chose qui favorise l'apparition
d'un cancer et on dit cancérigènes
quand on parle de quelque chose qui
favorisent le développement d'un cancer
la nuance elle est tellement subtil que
la majorité des dictionnaires et des
professionnels de santé a considéré que
c'était des synonymes et l'académie de
médecine a dit en gros je cite de
mémoire 1 on n'a qu'à juste garder
cancérogènes comme ça c'est plus facile
pour tout le monde en résumé je crois
qu'on peut dire j'ai pas pu m'empêcher
de vous la remettre j'aime bien mais
donc alors est-ce que les ondes sont
cancérogènes premier élément de réponse
si on regarde dans la liste du centre
international de recherche sur le cancer
de l'organisation mondiale de la santé
on voit qu'elles sont classés parmi les
substances cancérogènes possibles
concrètement ça veut dire qu'il ya eu un
doute un doute qui a été confirmé par
certaines études dont une qui a conclu
qu'il y avait un possible risque de
leucémie plus important chez les enfants
qui vivent à proximité de lignes à haute
tension
vous savez les lignes électriques et une
autre qui a indiqué que l'utilisation du
téléphone portable ça augmenterait de
30% le risque de gliome c'est une forme
de cancer du cerveau
mais cette même étude elle a ensuite été
contredite par d'autres études de plus
grande ampleur la science donc
globalement le doute subsiste mais on
n'a pas la preuve scientifique
on n'a pas identifié de mécanismes
biologiques qui pourrait faire craindre
que les ondes en dommages notre
organisme
on sait pas précisément ce qu'ils font
dans notre corps si vous voulez mais on
s'est quand même qu en cas d'exposition
prolongée et rapproché notamment
il ya un effet électrique et un effet
terminaison peuvent entraîner un
réchauffement et des micros choc
électrique qui pourrait perturber nos
cellules et l'adn qu'elles contiennent
mais on sait pas si ce serait durable ou
si notre organisme
réparer ça comme c'est souvent le cas
donc on n'a pas de vision sur les
conséquences à long terme mais ça
pourrait concerner la peau les
terminaisons nerveuses voire plus
profondément en fonction de leur
capacité à pénétrer dans les tissus
on sait aussi que les antennes relais
dont on parle pas mal en ce moment avec
la 5g pour le coup elles ont un
rayonnement qui est dangereux il est
dangereux de façon immédiate si on va se
coller à l'émetteur mais évidemment
personne ne fait ça ne serait ce que
parce que on peut pas l'atteindre mais
on sait aussi que ce rayonnement il
diminue quand on s'éloigne
c'est d'ailleurs là dessus que sont
basés les réglementations pas tellement
en termes de distance mais en termes de
mesures d'exposition aux ondes
mais quand on parle des inquiétudes
liées aux ondes on parle pas que de
cancer il ya aussi des doutes autour de
leur impact sur la fertilité et devinez
quoi
là encore on n'a pas de certitudes on
n'a pas assez de preuves pour affirmer
que c'est le cas mais ça veut pas dire
qui a pas de risque il ya des études par
exemple qui estime que les ongs
notamment le wifi et celle des
téléphones portables elles nuisent à la
qualité du sperme en faisant baisser la
quantité et la mobilité des
spermatozoïdes notamment pareil pour ce
qu'on appelle l'électrosensibilité ou
l'hypersensibilité électromagnétique il
ya des gens qui ressentent des troubles
physiques qu'ils attribuent aux ondes
displine par exemple de maux de tête de
fatigue de difficulté à se concentrer et
de nausées de troubles digestifs de
rougeurs et picotements au niveau de la
peau etc
leur trouble ils sont bien réels ça y'a
pas de souci là-dessus mais les études
qui ont été menées elles ont pas permis
de démontrer qu'ils apparaissent en
présence d'un champ électromagnétique
donc le lien de causalité a pas pu être
établie encore une fois ça veut pas dire
que ça n'existe pas ça veut dire qu'on
en a pas la preuve scientifique j'ai
compris la seule chose dont on est sûr
c'est que plus on s'éloigne de la source
plus on diminue les risques du côté des
antennes relais il ya des normes qui
semble rassurer les scientifiques dans
l'état actuel de leurs connaissances
comme d'habitude bien sûr mais au
quotidien il ya aussi deux trois trucs
qu'on peut faire par précaution pour se
protéger comme par exemple limiter le
contact direct avec le téléphone
portable genre utiliser un kit mains
libres à l'avoir dans sa poche en
permanence et pas le laisser sur sa
table de nuit juste à côté de sa tête
quand on va se coucher et s'en servir de
préférence quand on capte bien parce que
plus le téléphone capte mal plus il
aimait d'onde pour essayer de se
connecter au réseau pareil pour le wifi
vaut mieux éviter
et d'avoir son ordinateur portable posé
directement sur les genoux par exemple
et pour la boxe il ne faut pas
l'installer à côté d'un endroit où on
passe beaucoup de temps dans son canapé
tiens d'ailleurs tant qu'on y est on va
tester mon slip puisque j'ai sous la
main pas gelé sous la main non non c'est
pas comme ça que ça se met un slip
mais là pour le test le savez comment
certains scripts j'imagine alors
imaginons que je suis assis sur mon
canapé avec mon ordinateur sur les
genoux bon faut pas le faire mais
imaginons imaginons maintenant que ce
capteur qui mesure les ondes
électromagnétiques
c'est mon passé mais vous voyez quoi
imaginons en l'absence totale de slip
voilà à quoi mon matériel est exposée
testons maintenant un de mes flip
personnel on constate que ce qui se
trouve à l'intérieur reste très exposé
aux ondes
et pour finir testons nom super slip
[Musique]
je crois que ça se passe de commentaire
ça marche bien oui ce qu'on appelle les
ondes le rayonnement électromagnétique
en réalité ça recouvre plein de choses
du wifi à votre aspirateur en passant
par les lignes à haute tension ou votre
téléphone portables et les
antennes-relais
il y en a de plus en plus donc on y est
exposé de plus en plus en quantité est
quasiment en permanence on connaît pas
encore de manière certaine la façon dont
elles agissent sur notre organisme
et les conséquences que cela pourrait
avoir globalement l'avis des
scientifiques c'est on n'a encore rien
pu prouver mais il faut appliquer le
principe de précaution au niveau des
réglementations et individuellement au
quotidien voit la dtcc fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici là prenez
soin de vous et prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
bien